[Music]
what is the best cs class you've ever
taken
i've taken a lot of great classes but
honestly i think i
i really enjoyed uh 601 which was the
intro computer science class i took at
mit
my sophomore year and i really liked it
because it was sort of built around
making a robot and every week we would
build an additional thing onto the robot
so the first week we would just make it
walk in a straight line
and the second week we would try to make
it turn corners
and the process of interactively coding
things and then immediately seeing the
robot do what
i just told it to do was um
really fun for me and probably one of
the reasons why i decided to stick with
computer science
definitely in algorithms and data
structures
i went to harvard for undergrad and they
had a
an algorithms class that was notorious
for being the hardest computer science
class
in the entire curriculum people would
shake when they talked about it and i
remember being so nervous intimidated
but algorithms are actually quite fun
they're they are hard sometimes
and not everything came super easily to
me but i like the way that you can sort
of
come up with a little recipe and how to
solve this and then analyze how well
that recipe works and whether or not it
actually gets you what you want
i would say my favorite cs class was
intro to python and intro to programming
because that's what
got me interested in a lot of these
algorithms and research in the first
place
it was definitely a computer vision
and was also one that i took last
semester in season
it was particularly interesting because
i
i could see like aspects that i learned
before
and in a way that they are practical and
we even had to design
a camera for this class like a pinhole
camera
which made it particularly interesting
my favorite
computer science class is probably intro
to ai
it was taught by hodlipson cornell at
the time
and it was really interesting because i
was really excited about all these
different things
ai i wanted to know how did you make a
game playing
ai how do you how do you solve problems
in robotics where they have to navigate
a room
you know after after about like two or
three weeks i had coded up
an algorithm to solve there's this
there's this board game called rush hour
where you're trying to move
cars around and you're trying to get
this red car out of out of a traffic jam
and i used to play this game all the
time as a kid and after three weeks i
had written an
ai program to to do a search
and basically solve any level difficulty
rush hour problem in less than a minute
and it was just
it was super power empowering and i saw
all these applications that i could use
this for
for for video games for robotics and and
that was just really exciting about how
how quickly i felt like i was able to do
really sophisticated tasks
after learning that material i took this
my introduction to programming class at
uc santa cruz which was taught by
charlie mcdowell was
my first like big experience into
programming
and i really enjoyed the class because
you know i learned so much their data
structures
programming flow and some animation
so we used this weeds processing
and we made visual images
move and is my first experience really
coding anything
and i really enjoyed that so i would say
probably that was my favorite class
[Music]
you